hi everyone its Joe and I'm here and
today I want you to burn up to 300
calories in under 20 minutes so this is
a high-intensity total body fat burning
workouts you will be very tired at the
end but you'll be putting lots of fat so
what you need is lots of energy a bottle
of water drink as and when you need it
and just have fun there will be eight
different exercises will be performing
each exercise for about 45 seconds rest
for 15 seconds and on to the second
exercise until we've done all eight
exercises okay there'll be lots of
jumping so make sure that you've got a
comfortable pair of trainers on and
let's start by warming up are you ready
right let's just warm up my jockey on
the spot let's just bring the heart rate
up slowly and will you drink this for
about three minutes okay
so just drop on the spot
make sure you've got a comfortable pair
of trainers you can love this and let's
get into it
jumping jacks
it
I'm going to try to talk about adult on
top and not during the workout okay so
just amazing all right I'm going get
into high knees I think you shoot it all
the way up good going up anything that
you touch above
can you see a hundred going up good job
keep going
all right and use the chalk on this
point game okay
and before we start let's do some
dynamic stretches just to stretch your
hamstring out to prepare your hamstrings
and legs for lots of jumping okay so
don't feel quite a lot and just
appreciate those original gasps sighs
that's it rich and rich good keep going
you go you should put a scratch on your
hamstrings
okay and just gently slide slide your
items forward it circles
we're going back
alright are you ready so let's start
with the first workout there are eight
different workouts 45 seconds each rest
for 15 seconds and the first write down
its job squad
okay Sam I count three two one let's go
down jump good
Richard landing junkie okay going
I was there
keep jumping 15 seconds laughs can you
feel your eyes
five seconds keep going and rest 15
seconds okay good
the second workout it's push-ups if you
want to do push on your knees you can't
but if you want to push yourself turns
you on your toes okay and and stop go
down as many as you can
painful license
version
you
whatever assignments
Andres good job
what's the Louisville do things in is
nice the next workout burpees
alright you know purposes and McGee
let's go dumb out jump good Hey
good
as high as you can
we're going
the jobless you going
I know you're tired happens
more and last for me good all right
watch your your next workout it's a way
better apps
it's called mountain climber
all right really fun for second first
and let's get down on four let's go
bring your knees in good
it's it go on a trapeze really three
laps
I know everybody working good
keep going single sentence
with that final seconds
every skill Mohammed okay if we forgot
lunges point ready until so lunch
relighting good going
good job please squeeze all the way up
good
keep going
over there
do good job guys - come on 10 more
seconds 5 4 seconds and rest
all right I will get on three Moscow
next workout is playing and be shocked
okay stop line and push I'm ready let's
go can you take my position
okay
really - nobody straight all right
whatever
several seconds keep pushing
Andres good
thank you Oh Miss Ellie I need two more
nails next one is deuce okay so we're
just getting on the phone and we start
dipping right okay so keep your legs and
that can you go down and just go down
and up good
okay pushing good smell this why you
should really feel your triceps working
good keep going
good fishing
yeah
it was like this small but heartless
several seconds I am dreaming or what
good pretty one of those triceps three
two one and risk loss where y'all at
scrunching headaches 10 minutes and the
rest early
okay wedding dress nah circle I promise
it's a last word okay dumb Thank You
Virginia and extend up extend
oh so tired
15 more seconds keep coming up next n
let's end up good
final seconds in Lhasa in France
good job so that was in workouts in a
valise I love why I want to be doing is
to rest for 1 minute and then I'm going
to do the whole thing again and the end
of the workout you should be burning up
to 300 calories can you see that I am
absolutely dripping okay don't forget to
stretch I'm just going to show you quick
stretches when you finish your workout
so just stretch arms out all right
change side and just go down and reach
for your toes just stretch hamstrings up
straight what okay
you decide
clowns oops that's how I am
are you tying it
okay please arms behind and just open
your chest stretch your chest
if you just stretch your chest out
through your lungs together with your
circle and just stretch it back out
and just sugar all right so do to set
rest for a minute between sets no
resting throughout the whole x8
exercises and you'll be burning up to
300 calories depend on your weight and
depending it on your intensity as well
don't forget to subscribe to my youtube
page for more fitness and nutritional
videos as well as speakers motivational
tips share this video like this video
and make sure that your things high
right now